we're standing in Beeston a suburb of
melting ham outside the house where one
of my former colleagues Colonel Biddy
Shaw used to live
he was very famous as a lecturer on
explosives he used to demonstrate the
most hair-raising experiments and in his
honor I'm wearing a special tie you can
see here this is the tie which my
colleague Jim gamble burnt with white
phosphorus recreating when it be detials
experiments we're here now to put up a
plaque in his memory so everybody who
comes past the house will learn about
beady tall blue plaques are a UK
tradition when somebody dies who's
famous they put on their house a nice
blue plaque which says who lives there
and their dates and why they're famous
and we're really fortunate that the
Civic Society here has decided to want
to be do tall so let's put up the black
really good and I'm really impressed how
carefully it's being put up I never have
done such a good job I now turn off the
gas and remove the tin this goes more
rapidly this accelerates all the way
down the tube and the burning of the
first portion generate cause an
expansion this creates pressure on the
remainder and this also raises the
temperature anyone who's ever pumped up
a bicycle tire knows that the pump gets
warm and I don't look like a clever man
explodes even chemist and I would not
like before doing this the volunteers
with the fire extinguishers to step
forward
so Biddy saw kept some explosives here
when he lived here and when he died
the bomb squads had to come to clear the
house to make it safe but I visited it
before he died that I didn't realize
there was explosives in the house I
might have been more careful lecturers
don't seem to have time to do
experiments in lecture and this is a
great pity because it means that the
students never see experiments